The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open Courseware
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MITopencourseware@ocw.MIT.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: So I'm going to
talk about the gradient descent
today to get to that
central algorithm
of neural net deep
learning, machine learning,
and optimization in general.
So I'm trying to
minimize a function.
And that's the way you do it if
there are many, many variables,
too many to take
second derivatives,
then we settle for first
derivatives of the function.
So I introduced,
and you've already
met the idea of gradient.
But let me just be sure
to make some comments
about the gradient
and the Hessian
and the role of convexity before
we see the big crucial example.
So I've kind of prepared over
here for this crucial example.
The function is a pure
quadratic, two unknowns, x
and y, pure quadratic.
So every pure quadratic
I can write in terms
of a symmetric matrix s.
And in this case, x1 squared
was bx2 squared, the symmetric,
the matrix is just 2 by 2.
It's diagonal.
It's got eigenvalues 1 and
b sitting on the diagonal.
I'm thinking of b as
being the smaller one.
So the condition
number, which we'll see,
is all important in the question
of the speed of convergence
is the ratio of the
largest to the smallest.
In this case, the largest
is 1 the smallest is b.
So that's 1 over b.
And when 1 over b
is a big number,
when b is a very small
number, then that's
when we're in trouble.
When the matrix is symmetric,
that condition number
is lambda max over lambda min.
If I had an
unsymmetric matrix, I
would probably use sigma max
over sigma min, of course.
But here, matrices
are symmetric.
We're going to
see something neat
is that we can actually take
the steps of steepest descent,
write down what
each step gives us,
and see how quickly they
converge to the answer.
And what is the answer?
So I haven't put in
any linear term here.
So I just have a bowl
sitting on the origin.
So of course, the minimum
point is x equal 0, y equals 0.
So the minimum point x
star, is 0, 0, of course.
So the question will be how
quickly do we get to that one.
And you will say pretty
small example, not typical.
But the terrific
thing is that we see
everything for this example.
We can see the actual
steps of steepest descent.
We can see how
quickly they converge
to the x star, the
answer, the place
where this thing is a minimum.
And we can begin to think
what to do if it's too slow.
So I'll come to that example
after some general thoughts
about gradients, Hessians.
So what does the
gradient tell us?
So let me just take an
example of the gradient.
Let me take a linear function,
f of xy equals say, 2x plus 5y.
I just think we ought to get
totally familiar with these.
We're doing something.
We're jumping into
an important topic.
When I ask you
what's the gradient,
that's a freshman question.
But let's just be sure we know
how to interpret the gradient,
how to compute
it, what it means,
how to see it geometrically.
So what's the gradient
of that function?
It's a function
of two variables.
So the gradient is a
vector with two components.
And they are?
The derivative of
this factor x, which
is 2 and the derivative of
this factor y, which is 5.
So in this case, the
gradient is constant.
And the Hessian, which I
often call H after Hessian,
or del squared F
would tell us we're
taking the second
derivatives, that
will be the second derivatives
obviously 0 in this case.
So what shape is H here?
It's 2 by 2.
Everybody recognizes 2 by
2 is H would have the--
I'll take a second
derivative of that--
sorry, the first derivative
of that with respect to x,
obviously 0, the first
derivative with respect
to y, the first derivative
of that with respect to x y.
Anyway, Hessian 0 for sure.
So let me draw the surface.
So x, y, and the surface, if
I graph F in this direction,
then obviously, I have a plane.
And I'm at a typical point
on the plane let's say.
Yeah, yeah.
So I'm at a point
x, y, I should say.
I'm at a point x, y.
And let me put the
plane through it.
So how do I interpret
the gradient
at that particular point x, y?
What does 2x plus 5y tell me?
Or rather what does grad
F tell me about movement
from that point x, y?
Of course, the
gradient is constant.
So it really didn't matter
what point I'm moving from.
But taking a point here.
So what's the deal if I move?
What's the fastest way
to go up the surface?
If I took the plane that
went through that point x, y,
what's the fastest way
to climb the plane?
What direction goes up fastest?
The gradient direction, right?
The gradient direction
is the way up.
How am I going to put
it in this picture?
I guess I'm thinking
of this plane as--
so what plane?
You could well ask what
plane have I drawn?
Suppose I've drawn the plane
2x plus 5y equals 0 even?
So I'll make it go
through the arc.
And I've taken a typical
point on that plane.
Now if I want to
increase that function,
I go perpendicular to the plane.
If I want to stay level
with the function,
if I wanted to stay at
0, I stay in the plane.
So there are two key directions.
Everybody knows this.
I'm just repeating.
This is the direction
of the gradient of F out
of the plane, steepest upwards.
This is the downwards
direction minus gradient
of F, perpendicular to
the plane downwards.
And that line is in the plane.
That's part of the level set.
2x plus 5y equals 0
would be a level set.
That's my pretty
amateur picture.
Just all I want to remember is
these words level and steepest,
up or down.
Down with a minus sign that
we see in steepest descent.
So where in steepest descent.
And what's the Hessian
telling me about the surface
if I take the matrix
of second derivatives?
So I have this surface.
So I have a surface
F equal constant.
That's the sort
of level surface.
So if I stay in that surface,
the gradient of F is 0.
Gradient of F is 0 in--
on-- on is a better word--
on the surface.
The gradient of F
points perpendicular.
But what about the Hessian,
the second derivative?
What is that telling
me about that surface
in particular when the Hessian
is 0 or other surfaces?
What does the Hessian
tell me about--
I'm thinking of the Hessian
at a particular point.
So I'm getting 0 for the Hessian
because the surface is flat.
If the surface was
convex upwards from--
if it was a convex or a graph
of F, the Hessian would be--
so I just want to make
that connection now.
What's the connection between
the Hessian and convexity
of the--
the Hessian of the function
and convexity of the function?
So the point is that convexity--
the Hessian tells me whether
or not the surface is convex.
And what is the test?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GILBERT STRANG: Positive
definite or semi definite.
I'm just looking for
an excuse to write down
convexity and strong.
Do I say strict or
strong convexity?
I've forgotten.
Strict, I think.
Strictly convex.
So convexity, the Hessian
is positive semi-definite,
or which includes--
I better say that right here--
includes positive definite.
If I'm looking for
a strict convexity,
then I must require
positive definite.
H is positive definite.
Semi-definite won't do.
So semi-definite for convex.
So that in fact,
the linear function
is convex, but not
strictly convex.
Strictly means it
really bends upwards.
The Hessian is
positive definite.
The curvatures are positive.
So this would include
linear functions,
and that would not
include linear function.
They're not strictly convex.
Good, good, good.
Some examples-- OK, the
number one example, of course,
is the one we're
talking about over here.
So examples f of x equal
1/2 x transpose Sx.
And of course, I could
have linear terms
minus a transpose
x, a linear term.
And I could have a constant.
OK.
So this function
is strictly convex
when S is positive
definite, because H is now
S for that function,
for that function
H. Usually H, the Hessian is
varying from point to point.
The nice thing about a pure
quadratic is its constant.
It's the same S at all points.
Let me just ask you--
so that's a convex function.
And what's its minimum?
What's the gradient,
first of all?
What's the gradient of that?
I'm asking really
for differentiating
thinking in vector, doing all
n derivatives at once here.
I'm asking for the whole
vector of first derivatives.
Because here I'm giving
you the whole function
with x for vector x.
Of course, we could
take n to be 1.
And then we would
see that if n was 1,
this would just be Sx
squared, half Sx squared.
And the derivative of
a half Sx squared--
let me just put that
over here so we're
sure to get it right--
half of Sx squared.
This is in the n equal 1 case.
And the derivative
is obviously Sx.
And that's what it is here, Sx.
It's obviously
simple, but if you
haven't thought
about that line, it's
asking for all the
first derivatives
of that quadratic function.
Oh!
It's not-- What do I
have to include now here?
That's not right as it stands
for the function that's
written above it.
What's the right gradient?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GILBERT STRANG: Minus a, thanks.
Because the linear function,
its partial derivatives
are obviously just
the components of a.
And the Hessian H is S,
derivatives of that guy.
OK.
Good.
Good, good, good.
And the minimum value-- we
might as well-- oh yeah!
What's the right words
for a minimum value?
No, I'm sorry.
The right word is
minimum value like f min.
So I want to compute f min.
Well, first I have to figure out
where is that minimum reached?
And what's the answer to that?
We're putting everything on
the board for this simple case.
The minimum of f
of f of f of x--
remember, it's x is--
we're in n dimensions--
is at x equal what?
Well, the minimum is
where the gradient is 0.
So what's the minimizing x?
S inverse a, thanks.
Sorry.
That's not right.
It's here that I
meant to write it.
Really, my whole point
for this little moment
is to be sure that
we keep straight what
I mean by the place where
the minimum is reached
and the minimum value.
Those are two different things.
So the minimum is
reached at S inverse
a, because that's obviously
where the gradient is 0.
It's the solution to Sx equal a.
And what I was going to ask
you is what's the right word--
well, sort of word, made up
word-- for this point x star
where the minimum is reached?
So it's not the minimum value.
It's the point
where it's reached.
And that's called-- the
notation for that point is
AUDIENCE: Arg min.
GILBERT STRANG: Arg min, thanks.
Arg min of my function.
And that means the place--
the point where f equals f min.
I haven't said yet what
the minimum value is.
This tells us the point.
And that's usually what
we're interested in.
We're, to tell the
truth, not that
interested in a typical example
and what the minimum value
is as much as where is it?
Where do we reach that thing?
And of course, so this is x min.
This is then arg min
of my function f.
That's the point.
And it happens to
be in this case,
the minimum value is actually 0.
Because there's no linear
term a transpose x.
Why am I talking about arg
min when you've all seen it?
I guess I think that
somebody could just
be reading this stuff,
for example, learning
about neural net, and run
into this expression arg min
and think what's that?
So it's maybe a right
time to say what it is.
It's the point where
the minimum is reached.
Why those words, by the way?
Well, arg isn't much of a word.
It sounds like you're
getting strangled.
But it's sort of short.
I assume it's short.
Nobody ever told me this.
I assume it's
short for argument.
The word argument is a kind of
long word for the value of x.
If I have a function
f of x, f, I
call it function and x is the
argument of that function.
You might more often
see the word variable.
But argument-- and I'm assuming
that's what that refers to,
it's the argument that
minimizes the function.
OK, good.
And here it is, S inverse a.
Now but just by the
way, what is f min?
Do you know the
minimum of a quadratic?
I mean, this is the fundamental
minimization question,
to minimize a quadratic.
Electrical engineering, a
quadratic regulator problem
is the simplest problem there.
There could be constraints.
And we'll see it with
constraints included.
But right now, no
constraints at all.
We're just looking at
the function f of x.
Let me to remove the
b, because that just
shifts the function by b.
If I erase that, just
to say it didn't matter.
It's really that function.
So that function
actually goes through 0.
As it is, when x is
0, we obviously get 0.
But it's still on its
way down, so to speak.
It's on its way down to
this point, S inverse a.
That's where it bottoms out.
And when it bottoms out,
what do you get for f?
One thing I know, it's
going to be negative
because it passed through 0,
and it was on its way below 0.
So let's just figure
out what that f min is.
So I have a half.
I'm just going to plug in S
inverse a, the bottom point
into the function, and see
where the surface bottoms out
and at what level
it bottoms out.
So I have a half.
So that's S inverse a is
a transpose S inverse.
S symmetric, so I'll just
write this inverse transpose.
S, S inverse a from
the quadratic term,
minus a transpose.
And x is S inverse a.
Have you done this calculation?
It just doesn't
hurt to repeat it.
So I've plugged in S inverse
a there, there, and there.
OK, what have I got?
Well, S inverse
cancels S. So I have
a half of a transpose
S inverse a minus 1
of a transpose inverse a.
So I get finally
negative a half.
Half of it minus one of it
of a transpose S inverse a.
Sorry, that's not brilliant
use of the blackboard
to squeeze that in there.
But that's easily repeatable.
OK, good.
So that's what a quadratic bowl,
a perfect quadratic problem
minimizes to that's
its lowest level.
Ooh, I wanted to mention
one other function,
because I'm going to speak
mostly about quadratics,
but obviously,
the whole point is
that it's the convexity that's
really making things work.
So here, let me just put here,
a remarkable convex function.
And the notes tell what's the
gradient of this function.
They don't actually go
as far as the Hessian.
Proving that this function I'm
going to write down is convex,
it takes a little thinking.
But it's a fantastic function.
You would never
sort of imagine it
if you didn't see it sometime.
So it's going to be a function
of a matrix, a function of--
those are n squared
variables, x, i, j.
So it's a function
of many variables.
And here is this function.
It's you take the
determinant of the matrix.
That's clearly a function of
all the n squared variables.
Then you take the log
of the determinant
and put in a minus sign
because we want convex.
That turns out to be
a convex function.
And even to just check that
for 2 by 2 well, for 2 by 2
you have four variables,
because it's a 2 by 2 matrix.
We could maybe check it
for a symmetric matrix.
I move it down to
three variables.
But I'd be glad anybody
who's ambitious to see
why that log determinant
is a remarkable function.
And let me see.
So the gradient of that
thing is also amazing.
The gradient of that function--
I'm going to peek so I don't
write the wrong fact here.
So the partial derivative
of that function
are the entries of--
these are the entries
of a, a inverse.
That's the-- of x inverse.
That's like, wow.
Where did that come from?
It might be minus the
entries, of course.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we've got n
squared function--
what is a typical
entry in x inverse?
What does a typical
x inverse i, j?
Just to remember
that bit of pretty
old fashioned linear
algebra, the entry
is of the inverse matrix,
I'm sure to divide by what?
The determinant, that's
the one thing we know.
And that's the reason
we take the log,
because when you take
derivatives of a log,
that will put determinant
of x in the denominator.
And then the numerator
will be the derivatives
of the determinant of x.
Oh!
Can we get any idea what are the
derivatives of the determinant?
Oh my god.
How did I never get into this?
So are you with me so far?
This is going to be
derivatives of determinant,
the strength of all
these variables divided
by the determinant, because
that's what the log achieved.
So when I take the derivative
of the log of something,
that chain rule says take the
derivative of that something
divide by the function
determinant of x.
So what's the derivative of
the determinant of a matrix
with respect to its 1, 1 entry?
Yeah, sure.
This is crazy.
But it's crazy to be doing this.
But it's healthy.
OK.
So I have a matrix x, da,
da, da, x, x, 1, 1, x, 1n,
et cetera, xn, 1, x, n, n.
OK.
And what am I looking for?
I'm looking for that for
the derivatives of the--
do I want the derivatives
of the determinant?
Yes.
So what's the derivative of x
of the determinant with respect
to the first equals what?
How can I figure out?
So what's this asking me to do?
It's asking me to change x,
1, 1 by delta x and see what's
the change in the determinant.
That's what derivatives are.
Change x, 1, 1 a little bit.
How much did the
determinant change?
What has the determinant
of the whole matrix
got to do with x, 1, 1?
You remember that there is
a formula for determinants.
So I need that fact.
The determinant of x is
x, 1, 1 times something.
Is that something that
I really want to know?
Plus x, 1, 2 times
other something plus
say, along the first row
times another something.
What are these
factors that multiply
the x's to give the determinant?
What [INAUDIBLE] a
linear combination
of the first row time certain
factors gives the determinant?
And how do I know that
there will be such factors,
because the fundamental
property of the determinant
is that it's linear in row 1 if
I don't mess with other rows.
It's a linear function of row 1.
So it has a form x,
1, 1 times something.
And what is something?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GILBERT STRANG: The
determinant of this.
So what does x, 1, 1 multiply
when you compute determinants?
X, 1, 1 will not multiply
any other guys in its row,
because you're never
multiplying two
x's in the same row
or the same column.
What x, 1, 1 is
multiplying all these guys.
And in fact, it turns out
to be is the determinant.
And what is this called?
That one smaller determinant
that I get by throwing away
the first row and first column?
It's called a--
Minor is good.
Yes, minor is good.
I was saying there are two
words that can be used,
minor and co-factor.
Yeah.
And what is it?
I mean, how do I compute it?
What is the number?
This is a number.
It's just a number.
Maybe I think of the minor
as this determinant--
Ah!
Let me cancel that.
Maybe I think of the
minor as this smaller
matrix, and the
co-factor, which is
the determinant of the minor.
And there is a plus or minus.
Everything about
determinants, there's
a there's a plus or
minus choice to be made.
And we're not going
to worry about that.
But so anyway, so
it's the co-factor.
Let me call it C, 1, 1.
And so that's the formula
for a determinant.
That's the co-factor
expansion of a determinant.
OK.
And that will connect
back to this amazing fact
that the gradient is the
entries of x inverse,
because the inverse is the ratio
of co-factor to determinant.
So x inverse 1, 1 is that
co-factor over the determinant.
Yeah.
So that's where
this all comes from.
Anyway, I'm just mentioning that
as a very interesting example
of a convex function.
OK.
I'll leave that.
That's just for like, education.
OK.
Now I'm ready to go to
work on gradient descent.
So actually, the rest of
this class and Friday's class
about gradient descent are very
fundamental parts of 18.065.
And that will be
one of our examples.
And then the general case here.
So I'm using this.
It would be interesting
to minimize that thing,
but we're not going there.
Let's hide it, so we
don't see it again.
And I'll work with that example.
So here's gradient descent.
Is xk plus 1 is xk
minus Sk the step size
times the gradient of f at xk.
So the only thing
left that requires
us to input some decision making
is a step size, the learning
rate.
We can take it as constant.
If we take too big
a learning rate,
the thing will oscillate
all over the place
and it's a disaster.
If we take too small a
learning rate, too small steps,
what's the matter with that?
Takes too long.
So the problem is to
get it just right.
And one way that you
could say get it right
would be to think of optimize.
Choose the optimal Sk.
Of course, that takes longer
than just deciding an Sk
in advance, which
is what people do.
So I'll tell you what people
do is on really big problems is
take an Sk--
estimate a suitable Sk, and
then go with it for a while.
And then look back to
see if it was too big,
they'll see oscillations.
It'll be bouncing
all over the place.
Or of course, an
exact line search--
so you see that this
expression often.
The exact line search choose
Sk to make my function
f at xk plus 1 a minimum on
the line, on the search line,
a minimum in the
search direction.
The search direction is
given by the gradient.
That's the direction
we're moving.
This is the distance
we're moving,
or measure of the
distance we're moving.
And an exact search would
be to go along there.
If I have a convex function,
then as I move along this line,
as I increase Sk, I'll see
the function start down,
because the gradient,
negative gradient means down.
But at some point
it'll turn up again.
And an exact line search would
find that point and stop there.
That doesn't mean we would--
we will see in
this example where
we will do exact line searches
that for a small value of b,
it's extremely slow, that
the condition number controls
the speed.
That's really what
my message will
be just in these last
minutes and next time
the sort of key lecture
on gradient descent.
So an exact line
search would be that.
So what a backtracking
line search--
backtracking would be
take a fixed S like one.
And then be prepared
to come backwards.
Cut back by half.
See what you get at that point.
Cut back by half of that to a
quarter of the original step.
See what that is.
So the full step might
have taken you back
to the upward sweep.
Halfway forward it might
still be on the upward sweep.
Might be too much, but so
backtracking cuts the step size
in pieces and checks until it--
So S0, half of
S0, quarter of S0,
or obviously, a different
parameter, aS0, a squared S0,
and so on until you're
satisfied with that step.
And there are of course,
many, many refinements.
We're talking about
the big algorithm
here that everybody has,
depending on their function,
has different experiences with.
So here's my
fundamental question.
Let's think of an
exact line search.
How much does that
reduce the function?
So that's really what the
bounds that I want are.
How much does that
reduce the function?
And we'll see that the reduction
involves the condition number,
m over M. So why don't I
turn to the example first?
And then where we
know exact answers.
That gives us a
basis for comparison.
And then our math
goal is prove--
get S dead bounds
on the size of f
that match what we see
exactly in that example
where we know everything.
We know the gradient.
We know the Hessian.
It's that matrix.
We know the condition number.
So what happens if
I start at a point
x0 y0 that's on my surface?
Sorry.
What do I want to do here?
Yeah.
I take a point, x0
y0 and I iterate.
So the new xy k plus
1 is xyk minus the S,
which I can compute
times the gradient of f.
So I'm going to
put in gradient f.
What is the gradient here?
The derivative is
we expect to x.
So I have a 2xk and 2by.
And this is the step size.
And for this small
problem where we're
going to get such
a revealing answer,
I'm going to choose
exact line search.
I'm going to choose the best xk.
And what's the answer?
So I just want to tell you
what the iterations are
for that particular
function starting at x0 y0.
So let me put start x0 y0.
And I haven't done this
calculation myself.
It's taken from the book by
Steven Boyd and Vandenberghe
called Convex Optimization.
Of course, they weren't the
first to do this either.
But I'm happy to mention that
book Convex Optimization.
And Steven Boyd will be
on campus this spring
actually, in April
for three lectures.
This is April, maybe.
Yeah, OK.
So it's this month in
two or three weeks.
And I'll tell you about that.
So here are the xk's and the
yk's and the f and the function
values.
So where am I going to start?
Yeah.
So I'm starting from the
point x0 y0 equal b1.
Turns out that will make our
formulas very convenient,
x0 y0 equals b1.
Good.
So OK.
So xk is b times the key
ratio b minus 1 over b plus 1
to the kth power.
And yk happens to be--
it has this same ratio.
And my function f has
the same ratio too.
This is fk.
It has that same
ratio 1 minus b over 1
plus b to the kth times f0.
That's the beautiful
formula that we're
going to take as the
best example possible.
Let's just see.
If k equals 0, I have xk equal
b yk equal 1 b starting at b1.
And that tells me the rate
of decrease of the function.
It's this same ratio.
So what am I learning
from this example?
What's jumping out is that this
ratio 1 minus b over 1 plus b
is crucial.
If b is near 1,
that ratio is small.
that's near 0 over 2.
And I converge quickly,
no problem at all.
But if b is near 0, if my
condition number is bad--
so the bad case, the
hard case is small b.
Of course, when b is small,
that ratio is very near 1.
It's below 1.
The ratio is below 1, so
I'm getting convergence.
I do get convergence.
I do go downhill.
But what happens is I don't
go downhill very far until I'm
headed back uphill again.
So the picture to
draw for this--
let me change that picture
to a picture in the xy
plane of the level sets.
So the picture really to
see is in the xy plane.
The level sets f equal constant.
That's what a level set is.
It's a set of points, x and
y where f has the same value.
And what do those look like?
Oh, let's see.
I think-- what do you think?
What do the level sets look like
for this particular function?
If I look at the curve x
squared plus b y squared equal
a constant, that's
what the level set is.
This is x squared plus by
squared equal a constant.
What kind of a curve is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GILBERT STRANG:
That's an ellipse.
And what's up with that ellipse?
What's the shape of it?
Because there is no
xy term, that ellipse
is like, well lined
up with the axes.
The major axes of the ellipse
are in the x and y directions,
because there is
no cross term here.
We could always have
diagonalized our matrix
if it wasn't diagonal.
And that wouldn't
have changed anything.
So it's just
rotating this space.
And we've done that.
What do the levels
set look like?
They're ellipses.
And suppose b is a small number,
then what's with the ellipses?
If b is small, I
have to go pretty--
I have to take a pretty
large y to match a--
change an x.
I think maybe they're
ellipses of that sort.
Are they?
They're lined up for the axes.
And I hope I'm drawing
in the right direction.
They're long and thin.
Is that right?
Because I would have
to take a pretty big y
to make up for a small b.
OK.
So what happens
when I'm descending?
This is a narrow valley then.
Think of it as a valley
which comes down steeply
in the y direction,
but in the x direction
I'm crossing the valley slow--
Oh, is that right?
So what happens if I
take a point there?
Oh yeah, I remember what to do.
So let's start at that
point on that ellipse.
And those were the levels
sets f equal constant.
So what's the first
search direction?
What direction do
I move from x0 y0?
Do I move along the ellipse?
Absolutely not, because along
the ellipse f is constant.
The gradient direction is
perpendicular to the ellipse.
So I move perpendicular
to the ellipse.
And when do I stop?
Pretty soon, because very
soon I'm going back up again.
I haven't practiced
with this curve.
But I know-- and time
is up, thank God.
So what do I know
is going to happen?
And by Friday we'll
make it happen?
So what do we see for the
curve, the track of the--
it's say it?
AUDIENCE: Zigzag.
GILBERT STRANG:
It's a zigzag, yeah.
We would like to get here, but
we're not aimed here at all.
So we zig, zig, zig zag,
and very slowly approach
that point.
And how slowly?
With that multiplier, 1
minus b over 1 plus b.
That's what I'm learning
from this example,
that that's a key number.
And then you could ask, well,
what about general examples?
This was one specially chose
an example with exact solution.
Well, we'll see at the
beginning of next time
that for a convex
function this is typical.
This is 1 minus b is the
critical quantity, or 1 over b,
or the how small
is b compared to 1?
So that will be the
critical quantity.
And we see it in this ratio
1 minus b over 1 plus b.
So if b is 100, this
is 0.99 over 1.01.
It's virtually 1.
OK.
So next time is a
sort of a key lecture
to see what I've just
said, that this controls
the convergence of
steepest descent,
and then to see an
idea that speeds it up.
That idea is called
momentum or heavy ball.
So the physical idea is if you
had a heavy ball right there
and wanted to get it down
the valley toward the bottom,
you wouldn't go perpendicular
to the level sets.
Not at all.
You'd let the momentum
of the ball take over
and let it roll down.
So the idea of momentum is
to model the possibility
of letting that heavy ball
roll instead of directing it
by the steepest
descent at every point.
So there's an extra term in
steepest descent, the momentum
term that accelerates.
OK.
So Friday is the day.
Good.
See you then.